[Musique]
ce vendredi 16 décembre le collège de
Bras-Panon a été officiellement baptisé
le collège Fanny Desjardins pour
célébrer cette nouvelle dénomination une
plaque commémorative a été dévoilée par
le vice-président du département et
maire de brapanon janika Chapa lactrice
de l'Académie Chantal Maes bonissa et le
principal du collège Sylvain avione ce
nouveau nom choisi par les collégiens
eux-mêmes représentent le fruit d'un
projet débuté en 2018 c'est
l'aboutissement d'un travail de 4 ans il
y a 4 ans on a fêté les 170 ans de
l'abolition de l'esclavage et la
communauté a souhaité donner à cette
occasion un nouveau nom au collège
puisqu'il y en avait pas et donc c'est
parmi les quatre noms qui avaient été
proposés c'est Fanny Desjardins qui
avait été décidé
et en fait en faisant la préparation
avec les élèves on s'est rendu compte
que Fanny était porteur de
d'énormément de messages c'est une femme
issue du métissage qui a grandi toute
seule qui s'effrayait un chemin tout
seul et qui montre pour nous pour le
monde de l'éducation que le déterminisme
social on peut l'outrepasser et ça c'est
fantastique c'est un beau message pour
les élèves et de dire qu'on peut aller
très loin quelle que soit d'où on vient
la matinée c'est poursuivi avec une
présentation de Fanny Desjardins par
l'historien prospère Eve et une prise de
parole des collégiens un arbre à pain
l'arbre de Fanny a ensuite été planté
dans la cour de l'établissement
en ce jour de mémoire des ateliers
étaient également organisés pour les
élèves et les visiteurs autour de
l'identité créole
qui a fait sa marque de fabrique autour
de son courage de sa capacité
d'abnégation et qui illustre bien le
dicton qui veut et aujourd'hui je pense
c'est fier d'avoir cette
identité
qui plus est le nom d'une femme qui a
marqué l'histoire la Réunion en mettant
notamment au monde son fils Auguste La
Caussade et aujourd'hui c'est une belle
journée pour l'écologie parce que nous
sommes en train de visiter nous voyons
que ils ont vraiment pris à bras le
corps cette cette identité et qu'il est
important de se ressourcer dans
l'histoire de notre département mais
également construire à travers ça les
futurs esprits de demain au département
très heureux de s'associer à cette à
cette dénomination c'est sur une chanson
écrite et interprétée par les collégiens
en hommage à Fanny Desjardins que c'est
cette matinée d'inauguration
[Musique]